Wir hören sie seit Jahren.
Hier ist die Freak Show.
Wir lachen mit ihnen.
Bullshit makes the flowers grow.
Bullshit mit Doppel-O?
Bullshit.
Wir streiten mit ihnen.
Da fehlt es mir allerdings an Kompetenz.
Die sitzt hier.
Wer sitzt nur hier alle paar Wochen schon?
Wer ist denn dauernd in England, du Pfeiffer? Wir leiden mit ihnen.
Müssen wir wieder mehr über Apple ranken.
Aber was passiert, wenn die Mikros ausgeschaltet sind? Ist die Harmonie nur gespielt?
Das Doku-Drama Freaks Backstage wird es zeigen.
Sehen Sie Ralf Stockmann als Dennis Ahrens.
Na, die anderen Jungs interessieren mich ja nicht. Ich bin eigentlich nur hier, um Mitstreiter für meinen Bitcoin Pool zu bekommen.
Aber ich bleib wegen der Pizza. Martin Fischer ist Huckel.
Ein Glück, dass niemand weiß, dass ich der Einzige bin, der von Tim hier Gage bekommt.
Holger Klein ist Clemens Schrimpel.
Wenn die Meta-Image bald auf IPv6 umgestellt ist, bin ich weg. Dann heißt es Ciao Ihr Hinterwäldler, lebt Alena Steinzeit weiter.
Mesh-Netzwerk macht.
Ja, genau, das eh. Die Frage ist nur, was macht man mit dem Mesh-Netzwerk? Wenn man jetzt so rumläuft und sich sowieso vermesht mit allen, könnten ja im Prinzip alle Geräte die Daten über alle anderen Geräte auch anliefern, sodass man quasi über alle anderen Teilnehmer dieses Mesh-Netzwerk auch permanent eine Triangulation machen kann. Sodass man eigentlich dadurch so eine komplette Karte werbefindet, wo durchziehen könnte.
Super Idee.
Herr Uhl, darf ich ihm mal die Maske abbreiten?
Mal ehrlich, ich benutze ja hier Find My Friends auf meinem iPhone und das ist einfach der Brüller. Ich hab jetzt irgendwie hier so 20 Leute drauf. Und wenn ich so tagsüber so gucken will, wo geht denn jetzt gerade die Party ab, dann seh ich das halt einfach.
Ach, hier, Roddy wieder im Cyber-Sex-Teil.
Ich weiß, wer jetzt in den Zug guckt und so.
Ja, hier, Juri hängt da irgendwie an der Rakete ab. Warum ist der nicht hier? Ach nee, das ist nicht aktuell. Okay, deshalb ist ja noch kein Laden hier. Wird alles noch gesucht. Wie auch immer auf jeden Fall, Juri ist bestimmt hier, oder Juri? Das ist einfach praktisch. Das ist einfach, ich find das total super. Also wenn man so opt-in-mäßig da dabei sein kann und sich mit seiner Peer-Group so ein Realtime wer ist wo baut, dann wird einfach so ein Camp auch einfach viel... Ja, ist aber auch so.
Wenn wir jetzt hier auf einem ITF-Meeting wäre, würde jetzt da hinten der ACL Jumann aufstehen, ans Mikrofon gehen, sagen, ihr habt sie doch nicht mehr alle.
Die Frage ist ja immer, habe ich Wahl oder habe ich die Wahl nicht? Hier habe ich die Wahl und ich will ja auch die Wahl haben und ich will halt genauso schützen wie entschützen können.
Ja, aber das ist trotzdem eine schöne Anwendung, aber trotzdem, das machen ja alle schon. In vier Jahren hat jeder sein iPhone implantiert und dann ist es eh vorbei.
Nicht peer-to-peer ohne Infrastruktur. Hier geht das ja nur, weil du irgendwie so ein Netz und LTE und Mobilfunk und so weiter hast. Beziehungsweise manchmal eben auch nicht hast, weil wenn ich jetzt hier keinen WLAN hätte, was ich auch noch manchmal habe, dann bin ich halt schön in Edge-Land, Edge-Land. Hier gibt es für dich kein Netz. Du lebst in Edge-Land. Und dann war's das halt mit dem Tracking.
Wer von euch hat noch eine Rocket? Wer hat die in den letzten drei Monaten auch benutzt?
Wenige, wenige, wenige. Hier und da wird gesummt.
Aber die Rocket war halt auch kein Software Defined Radio.
Was ist mit der Peer-to-Peer-Nummer?
Die hat ja ein Radio drin, oder was?
Weil es halt keine Killer abgab. Weil einfach nur Blink-Lights-Movies auf der Rocket anzeigen, das reicht halt nicht. Du brauchst halt eine fucking Killer ab. Und ich sagte ja Peer-to-Peer mit irgendwie Tracking und Tra-la-la und bunt und jeder weiß, wo jeder ist.
Das ist geil.
Aber für mich funktioniert das.
Na, eine Killer ab, die mir sagt so, oh scheiße, wenn ich jetzt dieses Ding nicht jetzt, was ich sowieso habe, jetzt auch mal zusammenlöte, dann bin ich halt nicht mehr mit den coolen Kids unterwegs.
Aber kommt die Rocket da auch schon oder nicht?
Ich fände das aber...
Weiß ich nicht, aber es gibt die App nicht. Könnte oder könnte oder hätte, würde vielleicht, das ist das eine. Das andere ist, dass irgendwie da One-Button-Install, zack, bumm und dann...
Dann noch mal programmieren, Tim, und mach einfach mal.
Noch mal? Soll ich noch mal probieren?
Hat ja nicht gereicht, offensichtlich auch für die Apps.
Man ist nicht fertig mit Programmieren lernen.
Ich finde, man könnte das ja kombinieren. Hier gibt es ja Raketenbauer, habe ich gehört, die hier Raketen bauen, auf dem Camp auch. Und ja, die könnten die dann auch noch mal ein bisschen...
Das ist eine Self-Organization übrigens, ja. Es gibt auch Raketenbau für Kinder. Mit Schwarzpulver und allem Pippa Po.
Haben wir aber noch kein Schwarzpulver?
Die haben jetzt alle Raketen gebaut und warten jetzt da drauf, dass wir am Sonntag das Ding noch mal starten dürfen in kontrollierter Form.
Ich denke, die machen da nur so Co-Kleid-Mentos-Raketen oder so, oder?
Nee, stand Schwarzpulver im Workshop-Programm.
Okay.
Alle sehen, ganz ruhig.
Der Sandmann hat das Gate eingeschaltet.
Geil. Endlich kein Feedback mehr. Und kein Publikum mehr. Es ist wie in der Mitte eben, seid ihr noch da? Die TF hat da was richtig verstanden.
So, gibt es denn noch irgendwas, was wir über das Camp unbedingt berichten müssen? Fällt euch noch was ein.
Also ich muss noch sagen, dass für mich funktioniert diese Navigation und Leute finden einfach auch ohne dieses Mesh-Netzwerk, weil man muss einfach nur entweder an einer Stelle sitzen bleiben oder sich die ganze Zeit bewegen und dann kommen einem die Leute automatisch in die Arme. Letztens meinte auch schon einer, wie sie so ein Familien treffen und so. Aber es ist auch wirklich so, du triffst auch Leute, die hast du erst das letzte Mal beim Camp gesehen. Alle sind sie da und ich treff die halt auch alle. Und deswegen ist glaube ich auch das Camp jetzt fünf Tage, damit du auch wirklich alle triffst.
Weil man schon einen Tag braucht für Händeschützungen.
Kann aber sein, dass diesmal der fünfte Tag noch mehr fünfter Tag war als beim letzten Mal. Aber werden wir dann sehen, wie sich das entwickelt.
Das ist übrigens jetzt noch ein kleiner Pro-Tipp oder auch wieder von der Öffnungsveranstaltung. Haben wir das überhaupt gesagt? Ich weiß es gar nicht mehr. Ich glaube, das ist eine Sache, die wir vergessen haben. Für den Abbau gibt es gar nicht so viel Zeit.
Weil das Oldtimer-Treffen kommt.
Genau, da kommt nämlich nach uns ein Treckertreffen, wo alte Herrschaften, nee, alte Trecker von vielleicht auch jungen Herrschaften hergefahren werden und ausgestellt werden. Das heißt, wenn Fiona und ich unsere Abschlussveranstaltung da zelebriert haben, dann müsst ihr auch gleich schon eigentlich eure Sachen packen.
Nein, die müssen uns helfen beim Abbauen.
Naja, also unsere Sachen, alle Sachen.
Meine coole Apple Watch hat mir gerade erzählt, dass die Starterlaubnis für die Rakete morgen 11 Uhr ist.
Wenn es gewittert, ja.
Dual-Use.
Zwei Anwendungen.
So hip.
Das war's oder was? Da gibt's nichts zu sagen zum Camp.
Ja, du ist...
Thanks for coming.
Na, reden wir denn jetzt?
Da geht noch was.
Eine Stunde.
Hat er schon da schon? Haben wir noch, können wir noch aufzeichnen? Ja, ein bisschen noch, ne? Sollen wir noch ein bisschen weitermachen?
Das ist Verhalten.
Also nicht.
Ja, ich weiß jetzt auch nicht so ganz.
Wir machen mal ein bisschen Druck da drauf.
Uns fallen bestimmt noch ein paar Camp-Referenzen ein.
Genau.
Okay, wenn du was auf dem IETF Meeting......Meting....Meting.
Wieder mal.
Wieder mal. Weil du ja dreimal im Jahr bist.
Ich mach nicht alle mit, aber die so an diesen gammligen Locations. Nicht? Das war jetzt in Prag.
Ja, das ist auch hier.
Vor drei Wochen erst. War es sozusagen Heimspiel. War sehr interessant wieder mal. Wir hatten auch Sachen, die dem Camp zum Beispiel, oder nicht dem Camp, sondern dem Kongress noch nicht gelungen sind. Wir hatten nämlich am Sonntag sozusagen, an unserem Tag Null, hatten wir abends auch die Aufführung von Citizen Four mit anschließender Live-Schalte nach Moskau. Das war sehr interessant. Insbesondere fand ich halt eben, man kennt ihn auch aus den Interviews, er kommt so ein bisschen rüber als politischer Aktivist, aber der Typ ist halt am Ende des Tages auch Techniker. Der wusste sehr, sehr gut technisch, was da abgeht und hat eben auch einzelne Working Groups adressiert, was die da gemacht haben. Er hat auch Standing Ovation gekriegt. Was auch sehr lustig war, das hat ihm auch deutlich Spaß gemacht. Eigentlich die haben die Aufführung irgendwie um 22 Uhr gemacht und dann um Mitternacht ist sie gesagt, der läuft ja so zwei Stunden oder so. Mitternacht oder so war der Film dann rum. Und Moskau ist ja noch mal drei Stunden weg. Das heißt, das war ja schon relativ spät denn da bei ihm. Und dann hieß es so, naja, wir machen dann hier mal so drei Fragen oder sowas. Und das ging dann noch anderthalb Stunden oder so, weil immer mehr Spaß gehabt hat. Und manchmal, ach, eine Frage können wir noch. Und dann war halt sehr interessant.
Was für Fragen waren denn das?
Die sie an ihn gestellt haben oder so. Na, was denn so sein Tipp wäre für die ganze Standardisierung oder so. Weil ich sagte ja schon, er hat sich sehr bemüht, weil er nimmt auch so ein bisschen daran teil, was da so passiert in Sachen Standardisierung. Gerade so Verschlüsselung, so Zeugs. Und er hat halt eben angesagt, seine Message ist, ihr seht jetzt auch durch die Sachen, die jetzt da publik geworden sind, wird halt einfach alles abgehört, wo er nicht von vornherein fürsorgt, dass man es nicht tun kann. Also das, was wir machen, ist so uninteressant, das hört bestimmt keiner ab, was man so früher gedacht hat, das zählt halt einfach nicht. Und er hat sehr darauf auch beharrt, dass bei der Stabilisierung auch immer schön diese Sachen beachtet werden. Das ist auch das, was ich ja vorhin schon mal sagte, mit dem ACLU-Typen, den gibt's wirklich. Also die American Civil Liberties Union. Der ist da auch bei diesen Working Groups dabei. Und wenn da Protokolle so diskutiert werden, wo halt eben Nutzerdaten transportiert werden und da wird halt nicht ordentlich aufgepasst drauf. Oder man kann halt Drückschlüsse daraus ziehen auf Nutzerinformation. Dann steht der auf, stellt sich ans Mikrofon und sagt so, ihr gebt da gerade mal wieder Nutzerdatenpreis. Und alle so, ja, okay, gut, dann machen wir das anders. Und das fand ich halt sehr gut, dass da jetzt ganz deutlich mehr gegenüber früher auch drauf geachtet wird auf diese Dinge. Aber was wollten sie denn jetzt von ihm so wissen? Die übliche Frage war zum Beispiel, glaubst du, dass du jetzt doch noch mal demnächst mal nach Hause kommst? Und er so, naja, das ist ja ein laufendes Verfahren, da kann ich ja nichts über sagen, aber nö. Weil sie wollen ihn halt an den Arsch kriegen über ein Gesetz, wo du eigentlich nichts gegen sagen kannst, wo sozusagen die Regierung einfach eine Behauptung aufstellt. Ein Gesetz von, keine Ahnung, Anno Tuff, was so designt ist, dass die Regierung einfach behaupten muss, du bist eben böse und schadest dem Land, und deswegen gehst du lebenslang in den Knast. Da kannst du halt nicht viel gegen sagen. Deswegen hat er gesagt, da macht er sich momentan nicht so richtig viele Hoffnungen.
Okay, aber was war jetzt sozusagen ein technisches Interesse an ihm oder Einschätzung? War das jetzt nur so dieses, alles wird abgehört und sorg mal dafür oder ist er da auch mit seiner Expertise noch irgendwie anders befragt worden?
Es waren da nicht nähere technische Details, sondern waren eher so politische Fragen oder eben Einschätzungsdinge, wie er Dinge einschätzt zu solchen Themen, die aber eben alle auf die Sache hinaus liefen, dass er eben sagte, ja Leute, jetzt bitte passt ordentlich auf. Das, was ich hier mitgebracht oder was durch mich verbreitet wurde, ist nur die Spitze des Eisbergs. Seid halt eben einfach vorsichtig. Das hat er sehr eindringlich gesagt. Ich kann das jetzt nicht in einzelnen Worten wiedergeben. Das ist jetzt auch schon eine Weile her.
Aber der hat Spaß mit Nerd-Kommunikation. Also können wir ja auch mal im Kongress zuschalten und mal fragen, so Apple Watch und so.
Ich meine, inzwischen denke ich mal, die Geheimdienste wissen eh alle, wo er wohnt. Und diese Nummer, dass er jetzt in einem Keller sitzt ohne Fenster, ist jetzt auch schon rum. Und der macht eigentlich da ganzen Entspannten. Und ich denke, wenn man jetzt mal da höflich anfracht, kriegt man da bestimmt mal einen Interviewtermin.
Und was lief sonst noch so auf der ITF? Du bist ja mit so diversen Auguren mal wieder zusammen gestoßen.
Ja, ich hatte ja schon in der Freak Show, wo wir uns nach der WWDC dieses Video da angeguckt haben, hatte ich mir ja mal diesen Stuart Cheshire mal vorgeknüpft. Sehr, sehr netter Typ, sehr, sehr bodenständig auch. Haben uns ein bisschen unterhalten über die Themen, die Entwicklung. Ich hab ihm auch gesagt, dass wir das eben sehr schön fanden, dass ich mal jemand mal darum bemühe, dieses Schwanz beißt Hunden nochmal aufzulösen. Also dieses hier gibt es zwar einen technischen Standard, aber die Gerätehersteller implementieren den nicht, weil es gibt da kein Netz, was das kann. Und die Netzbetreiber sagen, ja, toller Standard, aber es gibt da keine Geräte, die das können. Warum soll ich das implementieren? Und dass das halt eben eine schöne Sache ist, die jetzt gerade Apple mal durchbricht mit ihrer Marktmacht, um da mal ein bisschen aus dem Kniff zu kommen. Und er hat mir aber auch zu verstehen gegeben, dass er das schon gerne auch nochmal lesen wollen würde, weil er möchte das gerne seinen Chefs zeigen. Also er hat es ein bisschen durch die Blume zu verstehen gegeben, dass die ihn zwar machen lassen, aber dass er schon gerne noch ein bisschen Support hätte aus der Community für solche Sachen. Oder dass ihm das gefallen würde, wenn er da irgendwie mal eine Zuschrift verkriegt. Hab ich ihm auch zugesagt. Wer da also auch gerne nochmal was hinschreiben möchte, der jetzt vielleicht was entdeckt dort, was die da machen, von den Apple-Leuten.
Hast du ihm unsere Show-Notes geschickt quasi von der Sendung?
Nee, aber das könnte man ja mal machen. Auf die Idee bin ich auch gar nicht gekommen. Was sonst auch sehr interessant war, insgesamt war, also das kann man ja vielleicht auch mal sagen, Apple und zum Beispiel Google bekriegen sich ja marketingmäßig. So Android versus iPhone und aber die arbeiten dort in den Working Groups sehr einträglich zusammen. Ich hab jetzt selber auch eine neue Working Group mitgegründet, die sich so ein bisschen befasst damit, dass wir diese scheiße WLAN-Portale mal irgendwie weg oder in den Griff kriegen. Wir werden sie, sagen wir mal, nicht komplett wegkriegen, weil es gibt halt Themen, die derzeitigen, die die derzeit technischen Standards nicht abdecken. Wie zum Beispiel diese so, manche Länder, die sowas haben, so wie Störerhaftungen oder so ein Scheiß, wo du halt aus rechtlichen Gründen irgendwie einen Haken setzen musst, sagen ja, ich mache hier keinen bösen Bit-Torrent oder sowas, bla bla bla. Soweit lassen halt die derzeitigen Standards nicht zu, aber es geht halt genauer darüber, dass eben so, dass wenn schon ein Portal da ist, dass er dann mit dem Gerät kommuniziert und sagt, hier bitte zeigt dem User mal hier folgende Text und lasse ihn da klicken und dann ist gut, aber dass man jetzt nicht anfängt, immer diese komischen, über diese Browser-Geschichten. Es ist ja das Ärgerliche an diesen WLAN-Portalen, dass du erstmal einen Browser starten musst, der natürlich einen nicht verschlüsselten Request machen muss. Da musst du also erst mal mit HTTP irgendwo hingreifen, wo wir ja gerade auf der anderen Seite dabei sind, jetzt alle zu verschlüsseln. Das heißt deine Standardseite, deine Google oder sonst welche ist ja alle schon lange verschlüsselt, das geht alles nicht. Das heißt, du musst jetzt noch einen Web-Sauber finden, der nur HTTP mit dir spricht, den ansprechen, um dann vom Portal redirected zu werden auf eine dämliche Seite, die niemals auf das Device draufpasst, auf das iPhone oder auf das iPad oder was auch immer du hast. Und inzwischen dich alle deine anderen Programme angreischen, dein E-Mail kleint, wie er sagt ne, die kann mir an den Server nicht aus. Und dein Kalender kleint und alles. Und diese ganze Geschichte, dass man das mal ein bisschen in den Griff kriegt. Und das fand ich sehr interessant, weil da waren wie gesagt auch die, wirklich die Leute, die den Code für iOS schreiben, den Code für Android schreiben, waren auch mit dabei. Und die sitzen dann da zusammen und sagen, so wie macht ihr denn das? Und die machen, okay, das finde ich schon irgendwie ganz okay.
Gibt es denn da jetzt schon einen Ansatz für den Standard?
Nee, der Standard sind wir noch weit weg. Wir sammeln halt erstmal, das war die Gründung von so einer, das war erstmal ein BOV, sozusagen Birds Over Feather Session. Und da wurde dann auch durch Summe eben abgestimmt, dass wir sagen, wir machen da draus eine Working Group. Und unterhalten uns jetzt sowohl mit den Portal-Herstellern auf der einen Seite als auch mit den Geräteherstellern auf der anderen Seite, um halt die Sachen hinzubringen, die man hin will. Inclusive Payment und so. Also erstmal natürlich dieses Zugang und abnicken, ja ich mach hier nichts Böses und la und so. Aber auch das Wiedererkennen von Geräten gerade. Das ist ja zum Beispiel auch der Nerv. Selbst wenn du durch die Scheiße einmal durchgegangen bist, du klappst dein Laptop mal zu oder gehst mal zum Mittagessen und kommst wieder, geht der Scheiß wieder von vorne los. Und all solche Sachen, dass das mal ein bisschen aus dem Kniff kommt.
Und Hamni, hast du sie mal befragt zu der Motivation mit dem IPv6? Ob sie da so richtig drücken wollen? Weiß man schon, dass jetzt irgendwie alle das supporten müssen, damit du Twitter noch benutzen kannst und so?
Meinst du jetzt die Apple-Jahner? Die Android-Vöge sind sowieso IPv6-Apologeten. Die Leute, die das machen. Aber Cheshire sowieso, der ist auch voll mit dabei. Deswegen sagte ich, aber das wäre halt schön, wenn er noch ein bisschen Backing kriegen würde aus der Community. Weil ich denke, der ist halt ewig da. Dem lassen sie ein bisschen Spielraum, was zu machen in seiner Firma. Aber er steht natürlich auch, wie alle Leute, die schon ewig in so einem Unternehmen sind, immer so ein bisschen unter Beschuss. Das muss denn alles neuer und toller und besser werden. Wir haben das gesehen, zum Beispiel bei Yosemite, haben sie ja dieses Bonjour kaputt gemacht, indem sie da diesen tollen, wie hieß der? Discovery Demon dahin gebaut haben. Ein wohl dem Vernehmen nach unglaublich grottenschlechtes Stück Software. Auch innerhalb von Apple so gesehen, wurde dann aber immer weiter gepusht, bis dann irgendwann ein anderes Liberty mal Tim Cook angerufen hat, gesagt, sag mal, geht's noch?
Eine was hat angerufen? Eine Celebrity.
Eine Celebrity. Ich kann doch sagen, das war Wind Surf, also sozusagen der Uropa des Internets. Hat dann mal bei Tim Cook angerufen, hat gesagt, ey Alter, meine Drucker drucken hier nicht, geht's noch? Revolution kann so einfach sein. Pass auf, die Story geht noch weiter. Dann hat Tim Cook natürlich so seine Chain runter angerufen, dann klingelte natürlich bei Stuart das Telefon. Und er so, ja, ich hab da meinen MDNS-Responder geschrieben, der würde funktionieren, aber ich versuch das mal zu debuggen. Und während die beiden dann da machten, also Stuart und Wind, kam dann Wind einfach auf die Idee und hat gesagt, pass auf, wir nehmen jetzt mal aus einer alten OSX-Release den MDNS-Responder und lassen den laufen. Und in dem Moment druckte das und Tim Cook rief an. Und der Drucker lief im Hintergrund. Und er so, pass mal auf, Alter, du machst jetzt einfach den MDNS-Responder wieder drauf. Und so geschah es dann auch. Aber es hat ewig gedauert, es hat Monate gedauert. Es gibt ja, wenn so unter OSX...
Habt ihr die Hack aber schon vorher rausgefunden?
Ja, ja.
Also das ist sozusagen die Lösung. Wenn man jetzt so ein Problem hat mit dem Apple, dann muss man einfach nur den Erfinder des Internets anrufen lassen bei Apple und dann läuft es wieder.
Wenn du, es gibt noch so andere nette Infos dazu, wenn auf so einem Apple-Ding was abstürzt und du das nicht ausgeknipst hast, dann schickt es dir ein Report nach Hause. Diese Automatic-Bug-Report, la la la. Und die werden auch wirklich bearbeitet und sortiert. Man denkt immer, die gehen da direkt nach Def Null. Nein, nein, die werden statistisch ausgewertet, zusammengefasst nach gleichen Problemen und so weiter und so fort. Und dieser Discovery-Demon hat über vier Monate hinweg von... Nee, die Top Ten belegt. Alle, alle, alle. Weil das Ding halt an jeder Stelle abstürzt. Überall. Das hat nicht bloß einen Wachs, das stürzt halt dauernd und überall ab.
Wurden die Zuständigen denn gestieft?
Dem von dem nach nicht, nein.
Mit dem Discovery-Demon hatte der Cheshire nix zu tun.
Nee, der hat halt seine MDNS... Die haben es immer gesagt, kannst du das mal in den Ohren bringen? Er so, ja, nehmt einfach mal einen MDNS-Responder. Der Ding ist halt alt, aber Single-Threaded ist ein Simplet, so wie man früher programmiert hat. So in C und dann so mit Select oder Poll oder so. Single-Threaded, mehrere Sachen, go to fail, ja. Und das andere Ding haben sie halt irgendwelche Hipster zusammenhacken lassen, die meinen, oh, das muss alles Multithreaded sein und Locking oder seh mal vorne brauchen wir nicht, deswegen stürzt das auch dauernd immer ab. Weil jetzt sich dauernd immer selber seine Daten überschreibt mit anderen Fats, also ganz, ganz übel, das Ding. Mit Herr Lang wär das nicht passiert. Aber aus politischen Gründen wollten sie das halt eben unbedingt durchprügeln. Ja, also da gab's wie gesagt noch diverse Sachen. Eine Sache, die ich ganz interessant fand, von der wir jetzt gerade noch mal bei ITF sind, ich hatte ja vorhin das erwähnt mit diesen DNS-Geschichten im V6 und DHCP und so weiter. Android macht kein DHCP V6. Und ich hab die dann gefragt, wieso denn eigentlich nicht? Das ist ja jetzt nicht so schwer. Und die so, ja, das hat Gründe, weil man kann mit DHCP V6 nicht nur DNS-Server-Adressen vermitteln, sondern man kann auch Geräten-Adressen zuweisen. Normalerweise ist das ja das, wie gesagt, wenn wir mit SLAC arbeiten wie hier, da sagt das Netz ja nur, hier hast du so einen 64-Bit-Bereich und da addierst du dir noch mal selber eine selbst ausgedachte 64-Bit-Adresse hinzu, um dann die gesamte IPv6-Adresse zu bilden. Das heißt, das Gerät sucht sich selber eine Adresse und wechselt die auch andauernd, so für Privacy und so weiter. Wenn du das Netz so einstellst, dass du sagst, nee, du darfst das nicht, bitte geh mal hin zum DHCP-Server, hol dir mal eine feste Adresse, denkt man erst mal, das ist ja toll, das möchte ich haben. So die Admins denken das. Es gibt aber auch andere Leute, die das gerne denken. Es gibt nämlich zum Beispiel Leute von der Content-Mafia. Die rennen jetzt nämlich inzwischen rum, bei großen Organisationen wie Universitäten und so, die so größere Netze betreiben und versuchen, die zu belabern. Sie möchten auch bitte DHCPv6 benutzen, statt SLAC.
Damit man besser tracken kann.
Damit man besser tracken kann, wer jetzt hier welche BitTorrents und so laufen lässt.
Großmutter, warum hast du nur einen DHCP-Server?
Und das ist zumindestens eine der Begründungen, die mir die Android-Leute gesagt haben, warum sie sagen, in diesem Druck wollen sie sich jetzt derzeit nicht beugen. Sie machen das nicht an oder wenn sie das anmachen, machen sie nur so andere Mechanismen an. Aber diese Adress-Fahrgabe wollen sie halt nicht. Unter anderem schon deswegen, weil sie dauernd Druck von ihrem Management kriegen, weil dauernd irgendwelche Leute von der MPAA oder sonst wo anrufen, sagen, mach doch das mal da rein. Finde ich immer sehr interessant. Also wenn man dann so ganz hinten um drei Ecken gedacht, ja, das ist eigentlich eine Technik, wo man denkt, tut doch niemandem was, doch tut doch niemandem was.
Warum hat sich dann ausgerechnet Google, ist das dann Googles Entscheidung?
Nein, wenn du da mal richtig reinzoomst, ne, pass auf, wenn du da mal richtig reinzoomst, dann sind die Typen, die das hacken, sind nicht irgendwelche Leute in Nadelstreifenanzügen mit Schlipsen, sondern die sehen so aus, so.
Vielleicht hier gerade eine. Wir kommen von denen.
Und die das immer so ist mit solcher Software, die, wenn du da tief genug drin steckst, dann bist du halt eben auch nicht so einfach zu ersetzen. Und dann haben die halt, dann sind die zwar Nerds am Ende der Foodchain, aber dann sagt das Management, hallo, wir wollen aus kommerziellen oder politischen Gründen gerne, dass du das tust. Und dann sagt der zum Beispiel, nö. Und das finde ich dann auch wieder cool, dass die Google-Jahner ihn da nicht einfach ausschmeißen. Da wüsste ich ein paar andere Firmen, die würden das dann einfach machen. Und der sagt halt einfach... Da hab ich jetzt keine Lust. Da sagt der einfach, da hab ich jetzt keine Lust drauf. Und dann macht der das einfach nicht.
Hörst du es nicht?
Vielleicht. Ruf den doch alle mal an.
Außerdem hast du auf jeden Fall gerade angehen mit deiner Uhr. Du kannst doch mit deiner Uhr dein Telefon anhängen.
Hätte ich jetzt auch gleich gemacht.
Du kannst den Airplane-Mode nur nicht wieder ausschalten über die Uhr.
Also es gibt noch 1.003 Anekdoten, aber die anderen Kollegen möchten vielleicht auch noch was beitragen. Ich möchte jetzt meine Cola trinken.
Ja, wir müssen mal hier über Bier reden. Willst du mit in die Sendung oder was? Ja, ruf an, ihr könnt so was erzählen.
Ja, da legt er wieder auf.
Aber immerhin hast du Netz.
Ich wollt ja nur aus dem Edge raus. Bin ich jetzt auch raus. Kann man dieses scheiß FaceTime immer ausschalten.
Diese Fliege da von deinem Display weg machen, das nervt mich total. Mein OCD springt da voll an. Darf ich mal?
Hopfenkurs, ja.
Ist wirklich sehr hopfig. Naturtrübes, untergegeriges Vollbier, wo kommt das her?
Ich bin kurz vor der Sendung von jemandem angesprochen worden und hab diesen Sixpack in die Hand gedrückt bekommen. Genau, da drüben sitzt er. Vielen Dank.
Sehr lecker.
Oh, es gibt einen Tanz.
Kann ich das auch mal probieren?
Ich sag mal noch was dazu.
Tim?
Was wie?
Kann ich deinen Hopfenkurs auch mal?
Der Hopfenkurs ist schon durch.
Der ist schon durch. Ich hab keinen weiteren Hopfenkurs.
Hopfenkurs ist untertrieben. Also es war ein Geknutsche.
Hopfenknutsch.
Hopfenzungenkurs.
Hopfenpferdekuss.
Wir waren intim.
Es gibt einen Clemens.
Ich hab sie sehr nah an mich herangelassen. Und jetzt gibt es hier Fidelio.
Den hab ich auch.
Brauerei Herle, Leutkirch. Ich weiß noch nicht mal, wo das ist.
Irgendwo, wo sie lecker Bier machen.
Eine helle Freude. Bio und alles. Sehr schön.
Mit Soße und Schar.
Clemens meinte, ich sollte das noch mal kurz erwähnen. Ach so, es gibt Clemens Bier?
Ne, das solltest du nicht erwähnen. Es hat jemand offensichtlich ein Transkript erstellt von diesem Edward Snowden at ITF 93. Genau. Weil man hat ihm wohl zugesagt, dass das nicht aufgezeichnet wird. Deswegen gibt es keine Aufzeichnung. Keine offizielle Aufzeichnung.
Das gibt's auf GitHub, den Link gibt's im Chat. Ich denke mal, das dürfte die Show-Notes-Kruschen eingesammelt haben. Okay, next. Dennis, was ist jetzt mit deinem Bitcoin-Zelt?
Das ist von der Ecke da vorne schräg durch am Ende. So ein weißes Zelt.
Und was findet da statt? Gibt's da so eine Art Bank?
Da ist ein Sofa da. Ich war da gestern nur mal ganz kurz.
Sagen wir mal, laufender Bitcoin-Maschinen. Es gibt ja einen Grund, warum der Generator da hingestellt ist.
Wahrscheinlich, ja. Ey, Alter. Die haben so ein paar USB-Mainer am Start.
Aber wieso gibt es hier keinen Bitcoin-Automaten?
Wollen die auch besorgen. Aber ich weiß nicht, ob es schon geklappt hat.
Aber so Bitcoin spielt ja auch irgendwie keine Rolle.
Nee, jetzt geht es jetzt hier und Bitcoin ist irgendwie nicht so. FIFA hat gesagt, verbraucht so viel Strom und dann geht das nicht. Ja, weiß ich nicht, das liegt ja auch an euch. Also ich meine, wenn ihr mehr Bitcoin macht, also ihr seid ja der CCC, ich bin das ja nicht alleine. Also ihr könnt schon auch das einfach benutzen und mehr Anfragen stellen und dann geht das. Aber ein Grund, was ich gehört habe, ist, warum wir für den Eintritt keine Bitcoins nehmen müssen, weil wir haben ja auch unseren Kreditkartenprovider, der irgendwie eure Abrechnung macht und der kann keinen Bitcoin und sie wollten nicht noch einen zweiten, der halt Bitcoin kann, weil das halt dann nervig wäre. Das wäre wohl ein Grund.
Ja, wahrscheinlich wäre es jetzt auch nicht so nennenswert gewesen, was darüber an Umsatz läuft, nehme ich mal an.
Aber du hättest trotzdem den Ärger mit dem Finanzamt gehabt.
Bestimmt.
Du hast da keinen Ärger. Du kannst doch, du kriegst die genauso wie bei den Kreditkarten, deine Überweisung rein und kannst genau sagen, das kam rein. Du kriegst doch am Ende die Dollars oder Euros direkt, so du siehst, du bitcoinst ja gar nicht.
Genau, die bieten nur sozusagen im Frontend für Bitcoin und bei dir landet dann eben nur der harte Euro. Also was ist noch da für nürrig geblieben?
Aber die machen da in ihrem Zelt... Ihr seid alle Individuen. Nee, aber die haben gestern einen Film gezeigt da, so ein Bitcoin-Movie, den hab ich selber auch noch nicht gesehen. Dann sind da wohl ein bisschen Vorträge, die wollen mich da auch noch einspannen, wollten eigentlich, dass ich einen Vortrag halte, aber ich hab keinen Vortrag über meinen Bitcoin-Pool. Aber ich werd mich da morgen wohl hinbegeben und so eine Art Ask Me Anything machen, so ähnlich, über Pools und Mining, so ein bisschen. Und ich weiß noch nicht, wann das ist, weil ich nicht genau weiß, jetzt wann morgen meine Schichten sind und wann die Zeit haben, aber die haben so ein Zettel am Zelt dran, wo dransteht, was sie so als Programm haben und wann man da so kommen kann und so. Ich mach Hinterzimmerkasse, ja. Das müsst ihr euch so vorstellen wie bei Scarface, da stehen die großen Geräte auf dem Tisch, dann kommen da so Leute mit so riesen Säcken rein und ich mach dann die ganze... und dann macht es ding und dann hab ich so ein Bündel in der Hand.
Dann gibt's noch so ein Spiegel mit weißem Pulver und... Deswegen wädert denn es auch so viel.
Ihr wisst gar nicht, wie viele Schienen so komisch und nur auf einer Seite so ganz hart geknickt sind und auf der anderen Seite dann immer weniger. Verstehst du nicht. 80 Euro.
Don't talk about it. Gibt's noch was zu sagen zum Thema Geld? Digital oder real?
Prinzipiell, wir haben Duschcontainer, wir haben Klo-Container, wir haben geiles Essen und so, aber so ein Geld-Automat-Container, dat wärt.
Oder überhaupt noch ein Geld-Automat, ne?
Was ich noch sagen kann, was es an der Kasse noch gibt, es gibt Duschmarken für die Marina, da sind wohl so Profi-Duschen, so kann man das nennen, dafür könnt ihr euch Marken an der Kasse holen. Fünf Stücken Zehner oder irgendwie so.
Was heißt Profi-Duschen?
Na ja, besser als hier, sonst müsste man sich die Marken...
Noch besser als hier?
Ja, was heißt denn das?
Ein Stück für Männer, zwei Duschen. Okay, aber was heißt denn Profi-Duschen? Dann wird man so gesandt strahlt.
Wir haben da so 100 Münzen oder so, das muss schon irgendwie ein bisschen größer sein.
Das Wasser ist warm wahrscheinlich.
Vielleicht, und vielleicht ist keine Schlange da vorne. Und man hat Platz, um seine Sachen hinzuhängen.
Vielleicht sogar eine Bank, um sie hinzulegen.
Ihr könnt es ja mal austesten und dann weiterverbreiten, wenn es cool war oder nicht.
Genau, für die nächsten Live-Show auf dem nächsten Camp.
Es gibt ja hier auch noch ein Open-Street-Map. Wenn ich es richtig sehe, ist das Open-Street-Map basiert. Genau, hier Campmap.dot. Ich fang nochmal von vorne an. Campmap.masdermind mit Z.
Fangen wir nochmal von vorne an.
Da wollte sich niemand nicht das nennen.
Matsdermind.
Es gibt da eine Map, da kann man sich irgendwie eintragen. Ist ganz praktisch, aber da sind noch nicht alle eingetragen. Aber wie ist denn jetzt die URL?
Mach doch mal einen QR-Code an die Wand. Warum ist der Beamer eigentlich nicht an?
Weiß ich nicht, kann ich da was hinschicken?
Der kann keine hoch aufgelösten QR-Cards.
Soll ich keine QR-Code hinschicken?
Der soll einfach mal Text anzeigen. Was reinpasten. Wie auch immer. Auf jeden Fall kann man hier so eine interaktive Campmap erstellen. Und das wäre eigentlich ganz cool, wenn sich alle Villages hier noch eintragen würden, weil dann würde man zumindest danach auch noch mal wissen, was wo ist.
Wo man was gefunden hätte, wenn man denn...
Genau, wenn man denn irgendwie Zeit gehabt hätte. Ich schau jetzt gerade mal, ob wir noch irgendwas Wichtiges vergessen haben. Ja, ah, da ist das Belgian Village. Das hab ich die ganze Zeit gesucht. Echt, das hab ich vorher nicht gefunden. Weil sie meinten im Wiki, sie wären nur im Westen. Das fand ich dann doch ein bisschen ungenau. Na, jetzt hab ich's.
Bist du wohl auch noch nicht genug rumgelaufen?
Nee, bin ich noch nicht, weil es ja auch groß hier. Also es ist ja wirklich nicht...
Wer von euch alles mit Fahrrad hier?
Na, ich.
War aber nicht so viel.
Dennis, weißt du eigentlich, wer sich diese Straßennamen hat einfallen lassen?
Ich hab so eine Ahnung. Die saßen nämlich in einem Club und kamen dann. Ja, wie wollen wir die Straßen nennen? Illuminati oder Gibson? Da hab ich gesagt, ey Jungs, seit 20 Jahren immer die gleiche Scheiße. Macht mal irgendwas anderes. Und dann haben sie auch was anderes gemacht.
Ja, und was haben sie jetzt gemacht? Irgendwelche Wissenschaftler, die keinen Schwein kennen. Und Wissenschaftlerinnen. Danke, richtiger Einwand von rechts.
Und gibt's jetzt die Hedil am Marschstraße, oder wie sie heißt?
Weiß ich nicht. Also ich muss zugeben, dass ich die wenigsten davon kannte. Genau, genau.
Ja, darum geht's ja. Du sollst ja kennenlernen.
Ja, nee, das ist ja auch in Ordnung. Aber hast du schon mal hinterher geklickt?
Ich hab noch nicht mal ein Straßenschild gesehen.
Die hängen aber seit zwei Tagen.
Ich wurde von einem Kollegen schon über ein paar aufgeklärt. Zum Beispiel den Namensgeber für Algorithmus haben wir hier als Straßennamen.
Und welcher ist das?
Der Al-Kwarizmi.
Dank für die Aussprache.
Wahrscheinlich. Al-Kwarizmi-Alleh. Ich wollte nicht sagen, dass es schlecht ist.
Also es ist besser als Illuminati und Gipsenstraßennamen.
Ja. Das stimmt. Das ist gut.
Tim ist befriedet.
Ist ja in Ordnung.
Und wonach sind die Veranstaltungsorte benannt?
Also die Datenklots sind nach Städten benannt.
Nicht alle.
Wie hieß unser hier Klemenz, wo wir gestern gepumelt hatten?
Warschau. Aber war die Kulfine wieder korrekt geschrieben. Also immer so in Landessprache.
W-A-R-S-A-W?
Oder doch nicht? Überlegereiweiß trotzdem. Ich glaube, es ist jedenfalls Warschauer. Unsere Daten gehen hier ins Warschauer Datenklo.
Ich denke, wir haben nichts mehr zu erzählen, oder? Nee, das ist alles keine Themen.
Das ist alles scheiße.
Das verdient den Namen Themen ab.
Das können wir jetzt nicht bringen.
Du weißt gar nicht, was das hier ist.
Nein, das ist einfach Kleinkram. Was ist denn das hier?
Hast du das eingeschragen?
Müssen wir uns darüber unterhalten?
Ich finde ihn irgendwie nett. Ich reiß das mal kurz an.
Und ihr wisst was, kurz anreißen bei Klemmenszeit. Holt euch noch ein Getränk.
Regie bitte, wie viel Aufzeichnungszeit haben wir noch? Naja, höchstens noch eine Stunde. Habt ihr doch keine Hektik? Also nur ganz kurz, für all die Leute, die hier gerne auch mit Raspberry Pis und ähnlichen Kleingedöns rumbasteln. Ich mach ja auch schon seit längerem was damit und erzeuge auch Software dafür. Wie viele auch schon mal gehört haben, bastel ich auch gerne mit Routern rum. Da gibt's ja auch Router, für die man auch selber Code generieren kann. Also ich rede jetzt hier von Arm- und Mips-Plattformen und so Zeugs. Und man kann jetzt entweder versuchen, direkt auf dem Raspberry Pi Sachen zu kompilieren. Da wird man aber alt und grau dabei, das ist richtig böse. Man kann auch versuchen, den Raspberry Pi zu emulieren. Da gibt es aber bisher nur so QEMO-Variante davon. Die emuliert nur den kleinsten Pi, der da raus ist. Und das auch sehr langsam. Und es gibt ein Projekt namens P-Root. Ich glaube die Webseite dazu ist proot.me. Und die haben ein super geiles, super einfach zu bedienendes Tool erzeugt, mit dem man sich auf einer normalen Intel-basierten Linux-Kiste eine Laufzeitumgebung erstellen kann mit wirklich nur drei Kommando-Zeilenparametern und vielleicht zwei Mausklicks oder sowas, die einem eine Umgebung erzeugt, wo man sich quasi in einem Pi befindet, aber mit den gesamten Ressourcen dieser Maschine, also mit nCPUs und so und so viel Gigabyte RAM und so weiter und so fort, sodass man eben auch mal schön make-j6 sagen kann und so. Damit bin ich also jetzt ganz froh dabei, für alle möglichen Mini-Plattformen Code zu erzeugen, Kernel zu erzeugen und so weiter und so fort. Wer, wie gesagt, einfach nur der Profi-Tipp für Leute, die damit basteln, klickt mal auf peroot.me.
Sie befinden sich in einem Pi.
Sie befinden sich in einem Pi. Also es ist wohlgemerkt, dass es jetzt keine Cross-Compilation-Umgebung, weil das ist ja auch immer so ein Nerv und so, sondern das ist halt sehr sexy. Ja, du guckst auf die Uhr, deswegen kann ich jetzt nicht näher darauf eingehen.
Ich gucke auf die Uhr, weil jemand im Chat meinte, ich soll irgendwas über die Uhr erzählen, und ich weiß aber nicht genau, was ich über die Uhr erzählen soll. Roddy, willst du nicht mal was über die Uhr erzählen?
Wir haben doch schon mal 2 Stunden über die Uhr geredet und sind dafür gehauen worden.
Aber hier, im Chat gibts was richtig Schönes, ein Wimmelbild vom Camp.
Das gibt es nicht nur im Chat, das gibt es sogar als Plakat.
Irgendjemand hat gemeint, dass die Künstlerin heute da war und man hätte sich signieren lassen können.
Die Künstlerin heute da war, die ist immer da. Die ist hier Teilnehmerin des Foxy Tellic.
Ja gut, aber die ist vielleicht nicht die ganze Zeit an der Bude und wartet auf Leute mit einem Stift in der Hand.
Das kann natürlich sein. Weiß irgendjemand, wo es das gibt?
Auf den Schirm.
Ja, gibt keinen Schirm. Ich glaube, ich selber das Wimmelbild.
Doch, eigentlich gibt es einen Schirmer. Ich weiß nicht, ob wir den jetzt irgendwie noch anschließen können.
Man kann ja noch erwähnen, wo ihr hier gerade sitzt, ist eigentlich der CCCB aus Berlin. Und wenn jetzt einer in den CCCB geht, dann geht dann nicht mal mehr das Licht an, es ist auch nicht mehr da.
Ist alles am Gebäude.
Die Leinwand ist irgendwie von da.
Das Display. Die Couches, LED-Lichter. Also alles.
Der komplette CCCB. Was natürlich eine einmalige Gelegenheit wäre, mal sauber zu machen.
Ist aber leider keiner da.
Aber das haben wir gemacht.
Der Kärcher ist auch hier.
Wir haben noch nicht sauber gemacht, aber wir haben einfach so viel mitgenommen in der Hoffnung, dass es nicht wieder zurückkommt.
Hätte man nicht hier noch zu den anderen Open-Air-Veranstaltungen fahren sollen und nochmal irgendwie ein kompletter, sieh mal, toller Zeug auspolen, von dem anderen in die Wette ranschleppen sollen.
Nee, das wollen die wieder haben. Da mussten wir auch sehr vorsichtig ausladen, weil es ist alles Kunst. Das ist ja schön.
Wollen wir jetzt am Ende?
Ja, aber was ist denn hier danach los als Programm, damit unsere Zuhörer und Gucker jetzt wissen, was wir jetzt machen danach?
Ich hab jetzt ein Programmhinweis gleich in 9 Minuten.
Jetzt schick die nicht alle weg, wir wollen hier noch ordentlich Bier ausgegeben bekommen.
Ja, das auch. Erst Bier und dann gibt es aber einen Vortrag zum Thema Musik machen mit Tesla-Spulen, wo jemand Tesla-Coils mit MIDI-Interface in Ableton eingebunden hat. Ja, nee, nicht hier, aber gibt es jetzt in einem Saal noch das letzte?
Na toll, jetzt sind sie alle weg.
Jetzt wäre das die geile Party geworden und jetzt wollen sie alle Tesla-Spulen angucken.
Das ist schon ein geiles Thema auf jeden Fall.
Na, wenn er sie mit MIDI und Ableton anschließt, wird er sie wohl dabei haben. Oder meinst du, der zeigt da nur eine Folie?
Die verbrauchen glaube ich ein bisschen Strom.
Weißt du, warum der Generator tanzt?
Der Fernsehturm, das ist es!
Es gibt hier ein Bastelprojekt, wo die so Beißhölzer machen. Oder so Beißstangen oder so. Wo man dann über die Knochenübertragung da so Sachen hört. Da basteln die mit so einem kleinen Elektromotor und so einem kleinen Leistungsverstärker was. Und dann beißt du auf so eine Stange da drauf und kriegst da den Sound dann, ohne dass die anderen das hören, kriegst du den Sound.
Ich dachte, das wäre für, wenn das mit den Strom-Experimenten schief geht, dass man...
So könnte man ja mal so eine Freak Show Podcast-Hörer-Event machen. So, hier ist dein Beißholz zum Zuhören.
Wir wissen nichts über System D, aber wir raten trotzdem drüber.
Ich glaube, jetzt haben wir unser Pulver verschossen. Also ich bin...
Jetzt werde ich langsam warm, ehrlich gesagt.
Was kommt denn?
Ich sehe das ja auch. Wie immer schlaft der Tim zuerst ab.
Ja, aber dann lass dir noch was einfallen, dass sie nicht alle besser aufstehen.
Jetzt hör dann nach auf dieser Bühne.
Ich weiß ja jetzt nicht nach.
Und es kommt einfach wie immer Sinnflut.
Können die da vorne und dann nicht sich ja so reinquatschen und dann sagen, was kommt?
Nicht heraufbeschwören. Die sind schon eingeschlafen. Hallo, das ist eine Open-Air-Veranstaltung, nicht Sinnflut heraufbeschwören.
Ja, Sinnflut kommt morgen. Morgen gibt es ja irgendwie NSFW auf der Bühne und es wird wahrscheinlich regnen, das wird lustig.
Jörnchen kommt. Wo denn?
Hier? Oder was?
In einer Stunde habe ich.
Ich finde die Information, die da angezeigt wird, finde ich jetzt gerade verwirrend.
Peter, jetzt sag doch mal was.
Regie.
Regie. Mats ab. Was kommt als nächstes?
Rainer, fahr ab.
Als nächstes legt jetzt Jörnchen gleich auf.
Dicker Beat und diesmal aber mit Limit, aber wir waren zu laut.
Genau. Und nicht wie früher, sondern wie in der Zukunft, so mit Tanzen und so. Ich finde das total großartig, wie viele Leute jetzt gekommen sind, keine Ahnung, es sind wahrscheinlich mehrere tausend. Und offensichtlich werdet ihr diesen Podcast und ich finde das total großartig. Und wir bedanken uns total auch für super Feedback und super Support und Tipps. Und Gesumme.
Gesumme.
Bier, Spenden, Klicks, Aufmerksamkeit, dumme Kommentare, dumme Kommentare, alles Mögliche. Das sind Hörer, die man haben will.
Das sind Camp-Besucher, die man haben will generell.
Höhrende Camp-Besucher.
Alles total super. Das war's. Freak Show. Live vom Camp. Vielen Dank. Und ihr hört uns bald wieder. Hat Spaß gemacht.
Dieses Podcast, schon verrückt, ne?